you
[Music]
all right thank you all for coming to
this session this will be the tidy first
session I have the pleasure of
introducing Karthik Ram for our first
speaker he'll be going over a guide to
reproducible analysis thank you all
right Thank You Shawn
okay today I'm gonna give you a talk
about how to make your data science
notebook or just about any art project
that you might have a little bit more
reproducible than it already is and I
just want to point out that at the end
of my talk I will give you a link to a
github repo that contains all of the
links the readme other demos and
tutorials and so on so feel free to
listen and not take notes just yet so
this is a situation that I frequently
find myself in I find a cool project on
github I try to clone it I can see that
they've got a few packages listed a few
datasets mentioned but even if I'm able
to install those packages the code
doesn't quite work correctly and they
start debugging and things don't quite
work and I don't have a beautiful are
markdown at the end I just have a very
very sad github repo with lots of errors
and then I just move on to something
else
and so the main thing I want to talk to
you about today is this idea of a
research compendium and this is an idea
that was put forth back in 2004 by
Robert gentlemen and Duncan temple Lang
and the general idea was that you can
create sort of this container for your
data your code and your text but also
take advantage of software engineering
principles to make sure that this
package that you have or compendium that
you have can easily be maintained
updated and then shared with everyone
else and so what I want to encourage you
after this talk is to go back and set up
a compendium for your project as as a
way to make it easily shareable and
useful to other people
even though setting up a compendium was
very complex and painful back in 2004
thanks to tidy versed plus dev tools and
friends it's a lot easier to do now
and so been Marwick Karl Boettiger and
Lincoln Mellon wrote a very nice paper
last year on how to set up a research
compendium or a practical guide to
setting up a research compendium and I
just want to talk through a few of these
ideas that came out of that paper the
first one being that you should just
organize your project in a way that
makes sense to you there's there are no
hard and fast rules about how to set up
a compendium many of you attended Jim
and Jenny's workshop over the last
couple of days and how to set up your
art projects all the advice you got from
there is excellent for a compendium and
so just do it in a way that makes sense
for people that you might collaborate
with once you've got that going for you
make sure you have all of your code and
your data and all of the artifacts
suffered from the outputs that you might
want to generate one way to do this for
data for example especially if it's
quite small is to just have a data or
all folder inside of your compendium and
then the last bit that is not
necessarily about docker itself although
I'll spend most of my time talking about
docker is figure out some way to
describe your computing environment as
as well as you can so that someone in
the future can actually run your
analysis or then extend the extended one
way or another and so to make your
compendium shareable and useful you have
to have four separate things one is make
sure there's a license that tells people
how to use it make sure it's under some
kind of version control preferably get
make sure there's enough metadata as
part of your compendium and then the
last thing which is often ignored
everywhere is that you need to have a
long-term archive so github is enough
not a long-term archive but sonoda org
for example it's a long term place where
you can deposit your compendium so that
it continues to persist even after
github disappears or any other services
disappear so it turns out that the AR
package structure is already a very
fantastic way to organize a compendium
and there's not really very much that
you need to do so many of you in the
room are package developers or or
everywhere in this room as a package
user and see if you have ever looked at
the contents of an hour package you
might see a description file that looks
like this this is a standard Debian
control format that contains a lot of
generally useful metadata it has a title
and author a version number or date and
then somewhere in the bottom it contains
useful bits like these are the
dependencies for this project but since
everybody is binge watching very condo
on Netflix I can make a memory condo
reference and say Marie Kondo the [ __ ]
out of this file and just make it a very
very minimal description file you just
need to say that is the compendium have
a title possibly a version number and
just your dependencies that are either
on cran or cran plus github simply
adding this file to a project and call
and get a description file makes it a
compendium and you already have a
research compendium now and once you
turn something into a compendium now you
can take advantage of dev tools and
friends so dev tools can help you to
make sure that your packages or your
compendium can be installed you can take
advantage of all the tools that help you
generate documentation and websites and
also link everything up to continuous
integration services to make sure that
your compendium is still working over
time so how do you set up a compendium
depends on the scale of your project if
you have a very simple analysis that is
just a simple are markdown notebook you
can have this sort of very minimal
structure just a description to read me
file a license and then the key bits
here that are different than a package
are that you have a folder that
containing your our markdown file and
then a data folder containing say a
small amount of data and this would work
for like a small project or a small
report but then for a lot of you you
might end up with a slightly more
complex compendium so the only thing
that's different here from the previous
version is that you have decided to
write a few custom functions for this
project
and this is a situation where these
functions are not broadly useful outside
the scope of this project which is why
you haven't written a package so these
exist within the compendium and now you
have a namespace file that captures some
of these dependencies but for a lot of
you your actual real world long-term
research project is going to be far more
complex so in this case you have taken
all of your functions and moved those
out into a separate package except for a
few that are critical only to this
project but that but the new elements
that you'll start to see are that you
have issues with keeping track of all of
the outputs that you have to generate
all the scripts that you have to deal
with so you need some sort of workflow
and in this case that is a make file and
then because your project dependencies
can change over time and packages can
change over time and the same package
can have API changes over time you need
to capture your computing environment
and in that case I have a docker file so
you will have to decide what level of
complexity you want for your compendium
and so for the rest of my talk I want to
focus on three separate components of a
compiler compendium and how to think
about them and how to use tools for that
particular purpose I'd like to talk
about data I care from industry I don't
have any good answers or solutions from
you you've already got a data
engineering team that can help you so
the advice that I have is mostly for
small to medium sized projects the
second one is how to isolate your
computing environment and then the third
one is talking about simple and complex
workflows so I'll start with data so how
do you manage data in the context of
like a small to medium size project well
a very simple answer is if the data are
small enough they're just tabular data
you can stick them inside of your
compendium itself because github lets
you have files up to 150 megabytes each
and the compendium is not a package that
is going to go on cran you can just have
arbitrary data files and if you want to
keep things very useful you can even
have a data raw folder that contains the
raw data and then some scripts that turn
it into useful data if you write a
package alongside your compendium and
you want it to
kranj you can include data in there but
your overall package size cannot exceed
five megabytes Nick Tierney and I
started poking around all the data that
exists inside of cran packages and right
now about 37% of them have like a ton of
data in there and some projects have
hundreds of tabular data files that are
shipped inside of an r package so that
is one simple easy solution that is
often overlooked another one that I want
to talk about is this fun little package
by Carl Bettinger called piggyback &
piggyback allows you to attach arbitrary
files these can be any kind of files up
to two gigabytes each and as many files
as you would like to a github release so
what does it github release if you have
written software before and you release
a new version of your software you can
tag it release on github and when you do
that you get a binaries attached and
piggyback just allows you to attach more
data files onto that release and the
functionality for this package is very
very simple there are only five
functions you can create create a new
release for your repo target but the
version number and then just upload
whatever files that you would like to
upload and when you do that and go to
the the release section of your github
repo is just your repo slash release or
releases you can see these files show up
there so you can set up your compendium
in such a way that when you're running
the code you can have all these files
downloaded back straight from github and
because github is a very fast CDN you
can get access to these files pretty
easily
no matter where you're running your
compendium if you've got a medium data
situation where you have a large number
of highly compressed text files that
contain data locally you can use this
package called arc DB that is built upon
D bi and it allows you to chunk the data
using your memory limits in and out of
any database back-end the d bi supports
so this is a nice way to either get lots
of data back from from from a database
or if you've already acquired data
through some other means this is a way
to use the limit
of your setup to get data into a
database all right the next bit I want
to talk about is isolating your
computing environment and this is really
important because even I can never
actually run any of my old analysis
especially things that involve ggplot2
from last year or the year before the
year before that I have all the packages
the code looks the same but nothing
really runs and this is a paper Nature
Biotechnology that talks about how
having just different versions of our
can produce entirely different results
from your same analysis or same code so
those of you that are familiar with
docker docker is a very nice way to just
containerized your existing environment
so that even if you change machines or
upgrade machines or move organizations
you should still be able to run the same
code with the same set of dependencies
and then get the same output back and
adding a docker file to your existing
our project is quite easy these days
there's an r package called container it
it's not a it's not on cran yet it's on
the on github but it can take any
arbitrary folder or get repo and
generate a nice docker file for you the
Jupiter project from the Jupiter
notebook team has a more general
solution called repo to docker that will
do it for either a Python project or an
hour project or products that contain
both and adding a docker file to your
project has many advantages one very
simple straight up one is that you can
then dock rise that particular project
launch a container run your analysis and
then get back out but I want to spend a
few minutes talking about this fantastic
open source project called binder or I
should rather say binder hub binder hub
is an open source project that allows
you to launch a live notebook from any
github repo on demand and let someone
else run this analysis poke through your
code make some changes see the results
for themselves and then when they close
the browser window that particular
instance is immediately killed off and
because
because it's easier to show you how this
thing works this is an example real
project from my collaborator Karl I'm
not on this particular collaboration
there's a button called launch binder
which once I click will either build a
docker container for the first time or a
docker image for the first time if it's
already found an image from before pull
it out of the cache and then go on to
install any other additional hour
packages that you might need that is not
already captured in the doctor file and
then drop you into an art studio server
and as part as it's par for a live demo
it doesn't actually work as quickly as
you expect it to but in about 30 seconds
or maybe a few minutes this will
actually drop you into a our studio
server I'm just going to let that run
while I go back to my talk yeah and so
you end up in an our studio server now
and here are the two beautiful things
that are happening all of the our
packages that you need for this analysis
have already been installed and all of
your scripts data and code have already
been copied in and there's nothing more
to do other than to open up a notebook
and then start running through it and
the way this works is that Jupiter hub
does 80% of this work and binder hub
just does a little bit of coordination
it reads in a repo sees if there's a
doctor file if there's a doctor file
that sees it checks to see if there's a
doctor image if not it builds one and
then hands it off to Jupiter hub to
allocate some resources to it and launch
a server on demand this service is free
and then my binder org is an example of
a binder hub and so how do you set this
up for your art project well there are
many different ways to do this and in
fact I'm not going to go through all the
different ways because that is going to
be part of my dreaming but a simple way
is just to add a text file called
runtime text and then add R and then a
particular date that corresponds to the
version of R that you might want to to
capture this also means that the rocker
project will pull all the cran
packages that correspond to this exact
date so if your project moves along or
your system moves along everything will
be locked in time and then you have
another text file called install that
are that just contains a list of package
install commands this is the simple most
basic way to set this up then you can go
to my binder org paste the URL for your
github repo click Launch
add that binder button and then you
should be good to go so this is the
basic approach adding an installed on
our runtime text and then if you want to
add any Linux dependencies you can add
an app text the only downside is it's
very slow and every time you change
anything it'll take hours to rebuild
your docker image but then there's a
faster way to do this is by adding a
docker file using one of those two
packages like container it or repo to
docker and because we're going to use a
docker image that already contains
tiburce things will move along very
quickly and then the pro option is
because now you're all experts on
research company and you already have a
description file then you just need to
add a very very short docker file it
could even just be four lines that says
start at this base image move all my
files into my container and then install
these few additional packages for my
description those of you that don't know
about the rocker project it contains
daily versions of different instances of
are including ones that contain our
studio and then specialized ones for
geospatial data and so on the last one
that I want to talk about our workflows
so I imagine that a lot of people in
this room are quite familiar with make
files and Karl Berman who's in here in
this room has a fantastic tutorial on
make files and so having a make file
somewhere inside of your compendium
allows you to keep track of all of your
scripts and all of your inputs and
outputs but those of you that have used
make files probably know that it can get
cumbersome very very quickly it's the
the wild card syntax is not intuitive to
remember like I have to Google this
thing every damn time and then it
generates so much output that it just
clutters your compendium every single
time you run so
thing so I want to give a shout out to a
fantastic project called Drake which is
also part of our up inside the author
for this project bill Landau is in the
room somewhere and you should go talk to
him if you're interested in talking
about Drake
and what Drake is is if you want to
think about a piece of software that
mimics make but it's very r centric
that's what Drake is and Drake stands
for data frames in r4 make and of course
it is impossible for me to do a demo in
the amount of time that I have left but
I want to mention that what Drake allows
you to do is generate these very very
complex make files without writing them
out it does beautiful wildcard
expansions and then takes advantage of
numerous parallel backends including
things like future it gives you a nice
dependency graph with all of your inputs
expanded and then it also estimated
runtimes and because it uses a system
called store sto R R as the backend it
does not clutter your entire environment
and allows you to quickly read outputs
back as and when you need them and then
this is what this would be a beautiful
dependency graph that it generates it's
an interactive graph you can actually
see runtimes missing objects and all the
relationships but in your workflow so
having Drake as part of your compendium
instead of a make file can be a nice way
for you to scale very large projects and
then the author will actually develop
this for a real world use case for a
very complex Bayesian analysis project
so I have to take home messages for you
one is that turning your project into a
research compendium is as simple as
throwing in a description file in there
and it can be a very very minimal
description file the tiny bits of
metadata dependencies and then you can
use these modern tools like binder to
launch notebooks that make it more
accessible for people trying to
understand your analysis but at the same
time all these solutions like binder and
piggyback are designed to help you but I
cannot guarantee that github will remain
around forever or binder will remain
around forever but for example having
your data exported in some flat file
format and throwing it in sonoda would
be a nice long-term archive but for the
short term
piggyback will help you run your
analysis pretty quickly same thing with
binder binder we'll just look for the
docker file launch a beautiful our
studio server and if binder ever goes
away you still have a doctor file and I
think docker will still be around for
another five years and then Drake also
conveniently exports the entire workflow
out of Drake into just basic art so at
some point you have a collaborator who
hates Drake just pull the whole thing
out so that is my talk and this is where
I would like to get you to everything
beautifully works and the last bit is a
docker file in there and then I have a
very detailed to read me here that
includes a lot of links and stuff so
thank you
[Applause]
you
you
[Music]